the ground is shaking the moving
mountainside was a warning of much worse
to come
these Everest Mountaineers since
something is wrong and then a few
terrifying seconds they realize a giant
wall of snow ice and rock crashes into
their Himalayan Basecamp still alive
sheltering under a jacket and trying to
take in Walt has just happened
[Music]
the Avalanche spreads panic and
confusion
this orientated climbers scramble
desperate to search for their teammates
they have no idea if there are more
landslides to follow but know that they
must account quickly for any missing
people the camp has been wiped out some
climbers have been killed and others
have been injured what nobody up here
could know is that this deadly avalanche
has been triggered by a massive
earthquake it's just after midday on
Saturday
the ancient capital of Kathmandu has
been struck by a 7.8 magnitude quake in
moments the cityscape changes
dramatically buildings homes offices
shops reduced to rubble
trapping inside unsuspecting people
thousands
emergency services overwhelmed and
under-resourced struggle under the sheer
enormity of the devastation my mom was
crying and my brother was crying and we
just held ourselves very tight and
witnessed the wall just aside us falling
down and we could just hear the scream
all all over the places people just
trying to run out I barely walk from
this this road carrying my mom to this
dislocation the small school out here
and you can see many of the people still
outside the force of the quake could be
felt across the Himalayan region these
terrified diners fled into the streets
when their Tibetan restaurant shook
violently other images from across the
region show the full force of the tremor
and still trying to cope with the
disaster a series of aftershocks are
followed brought the same unrelenting
terror
adding to the considerable challenge
already faced by aid workers we have the
capacity of getting water two hundred
thousand people so yeah this is now
setting a set in motion its trembling
I'm going outside I'm really sorry
bye the injured were rushed to the
hospitals that remained standing and
where there were no established medical
centers field hospital sprung up to
offer what assistance they could the
sheer volume of victims requiring help
meant they were quickly overrun most of
them are suffering from head injuries
they got many people who are serious are
sipping some tea from head injuries and
the [ __ ] movies spine injuries
abdominal injuries this is one of the
biggest earthquakes to hit the region
and it became obvious very quickly the
loss of life would be huge the number of
reported dead rose sharply within hours
my father got injured I lost my daughter
broke my leg it is very difficult
heartbreaking testimony like this was
becoming all too familiar but this
tragedy was not limited to the Capitol
and it's nearby neighborhoods the death
and destruction across the valley in
remote rural mountain communities could
not even be guessed at it could take
days or even weeks before aid workers
can reach these people who are now cut
off from the rest of the country
and this is why some of the only roads
into these areas made completely
impossible but the tales from the
survivors making it back down the
mountainside tell of a major emergency
the mountain that provides a livelihood
for the Sherpa families has become a
snow-covered craggy graveyard some may
never return to their devastated
families okay here we have another have
an answer and it just happened right now
and it's from pomorie it's coming over
the hill now this is peak season for
Everest a sense hundreds of thousands of
adventurers from all over the world come
with the intention of realizing a
lifetime's dream of conquering the
world's highest mountain expeditions
already under way have survived and
witnessed the mountain shape with them
some people have gone up towards camp
one we should learn from them soon they
were more than eight hundred people at
different altitudes in the mountain when
the quake triggered the Avalanche
some 150 who had been stranded for two
days before helicopter rescue flights
could resume comes one and two have now
been flown back to safety many know how
close they have come to death so I told
the group to get down it just uh it was
like four thousand feet of snow just
kind of come aid there's no word of Rudd
so I told me buddy get down and then I
put my heads over my head like just bury
myself as much as I could
basically snow hit about 45 seconds or a
minute for it to go by all our tents
were gone and then like people were
pushed like a guy with who stood in
front of me was now 30 feet over there
and we were missing one person that we
don't know what she's alive or dead the
immediate emergency on Everest may be
coming to an end the misery for the rest
of Nepal is only just becoming clearer
there are thought to be dozens of
villages and towns home to thousands of
people that have simply been wiped out
this aerial footage in Gorka province
close to the epicenter of the earthquake
shows the splintered remains of these
devastated communities helicopters
provide a lifeline this Indian Air Force
flight brings in and distributes vital
supplies
and then crucially it serves as an air
ambulance to medevac
critically injured villages the
priorities really are going to be water
and sanitation and shelter basic shelter
helping people to get their lives back
together it's very important along with
basic humanitarian work on water
sanitation and housing and shelter to
really try and work with families to get
children back into some feeling of
normal life and that's but possible the
way things are around here the search
and rescue phase of this operation is
still very much alive with the right
expertise and equipment the chances of
finding survivors trapped underneath the
rubble is still good this young man was
pulled out by a Turkish team that
arrived in Nepal just 24 hours ago but
every miraculous rescue is tempered by
the discovery of yet another body and
there are so many it seems like every
family here has lost someone
[Music]
Theater logo God did woody I'm me we've
taken out 13 dead bodies and we have
rescued six people we think about 14
bodies are still inside the rubble yeah
yes yeah a gives me a Vivi get us all to
look IV one game it's me
as the smoke from open funeral pyres
drifts across Katmandu the focus shifts
from Nepal's dead to her living tens of
thousands have lost everything the
international community has responded
generously and quickly but the people
here are in desperate need of more help
we need indecision like food teams and
clothes and now really we need
equipments we need equipments for the
dozer like a bulldozer and crane some
scaffold and the like we need because a
lot of people there people die inside I
mean the dead body inside the house so
it's very we need that to pick up I mean
take out all the dead body
this small poor Hindu nation has
suffered from one of her worst disasters
has scarred capital with centuries old
buildings now lying in ruins the past
destroyed the future uncertain the roof
of the world has been shaken to it's
very core